what's with the jeans we will have lots
of zombies and we'll just story dangle
brains in front of them and then they
will turn the giant turbines creating
energy hmm that makes sense he makes
more sense than Trump I think he makes a
lot more sense than Trump and the the
whole I tell you the idea that I didn't
know there were that many stupid people
yeah I knew that there was a lot of
stupid people I didn't know there were
that many yeah it's really appalling
that people are and I think it's such
people my family are even ended from
what yeah
really very bad who can't tell you won't
tell you off the air off the air it's
intense right it's so dumb it's so
dumb he's the dumbest buffoon
ever I mean he's a failed businessman
he's a he's just a complete he's a
megalomaniac a personality disorder yeah
we're talking about a guy that just has
filed bankruptcy five times and
you know he just licenses his name's out
the place it's the only thing he's not
even like a really savvy businessman
yeah and he's a bigot pretty openly it's
kind of crazy so annoying I mean
yeah I actually feel bad for
conservative people because he's not one
of you you know he's not a conservative
he doesn't really give a show no he's
just like whatever what are you doing I
don't know hey I think you're selling my
favorite Oh so I I just it's horrible
this guy's got some I'm saying this
guy's got ideas I know that's the other
thing is Trump actually doesn't know any
policy stuff yeah if you if you bring up
any point well what are you gonna do
about immigration you're gonna see a lot
of things are gonna be different right
what about terrorism it's gonna be way
different when I get in there you'll see
I'm not gonna I'm gonna get pushed
around anymore oh okay yeah great that's
really cool number two of course
time-travel research I'm military will
go back in time I am a little baby
Hitler with my bare hands before he
number four what about Jeb Bush well
once again Jeb Bush said he would kill
baby Hitler
hell yeah would I say I'm God he's
promising he's going to go and kill baby
Hitler
that's huge Wow I mean huge politician
nowadays will make such bold claims but
a lot
the wizard Wow yeah that's awesome and
the thing that I want to know is how
will that affect this drop I mean you
realize if he actually does what he says
gonna do when I go to press that button
there will be nothing there'll be
nothing - oh you're right yeah
time travel wow this kind of ruins a few
episodes of our show yeah we're gonna
have to write into this guy yeah dude
maybe could I don't know maybe one okay
yeah so now now you're seeing somebody
who's out of the box but makes sense yep
not like Trump it does make more sense
yeah and then of course mandatory tooth
brushing laws this has been eroding the
gumline of this great nation of ours who
too long this great country has been
stopped for any great moral and aural
decay in spear and incisors our
country's future depends on us on its
ability to bite back we can no longer be
a nation indentured our very salvation
is at stake when this mandatory
toothbrush law is really about is strong
team for strong America
may we become a sea of shiny smiling
shiny smiling shiny smiling smiling
smiling smiling shiny faces from sea to
shining sea thank you my parents agree
wow there's a lot of stuff that's tapped
into the show weird
yeah dinna dental updates he's in - hey
Hitler he's into all of it men Wow
yeah Wow but I will say that he wants us
this feels okay he wants to stop saying
hey learn but you know I would say that
in this case that makes sense yeah you
know but he definitely likes dental
updates clearly and again those that the
little bit we've seen here much more
policy savvy than Donald Trump yeah he
actually has tangible ideas yeah real
ideas real plans one
Oh number three of course three ponies
for all Americans
it is of course a job stimulus creation
program and it is a federal Pony
identification program we have to raise
taxes for that know they're free ponies